the whole situation is very alarming the
latest nuclear test in North Korea is a
severe violation of the country's
obligations to stop testing and
producing nuclear weapons it's a major
provocation and it's also a large threat
not only to regional but also to
international security the message of
the European Union is clear we want
North Korea to abandon its nuclear
weapons other weapons of mass
destruction and also the ballistic
missile programs we must solve this
crisis diplomatically it's the only
solution possible and that's why the
European Union is supporting to tighten
the economic sanctions on the regime in
Pyongyang I believe if we for instance
further tighten the supply of oil to
North Korea that would have a major
impact on the economy and in the end of
the regime in North Korea
I think what we really need now is a
clear message from the international
world not only from the Europeans and
the Americans but also Russia will play
a key role and certainly China and China
must make very clear to North Korea that
this major provocation is an acceptable
of course the European Union is not a
direct player in the region but as a
soft power with diplomatic skills and
economic influence we can of course also
play a role and the European Union's
also offered to facilitate a dialogue
between the parties if this is requested